T
PLEASE?
ANYWAY, THESE BIZARRE MENTAL
AREAS, THEY ARE COMMONPLACE,
IT'S NOT JUST THE VERBAL GAS,
JOE BIDEN ALSO SEEMS TO BE
HAVING TROUBLE WITH SOMETHING
CALLED IT TELLING THE TRUTH,
BECAUSE TODAY BY DENNIS OUT
THERE CLAIMING HIS MULTITRILLION
DOLLAR TAX HIKE WON'T COST ANYBY
ANYTHING.
NOTHING.
>> President Biden: WE'VE GOT
TO COMPETE.
IT DOESN'T COST ANYBODY ANYTHING
AND DEPRIVE ANYBODY FROM
ANYTHING THEY HAVE EARNED OR
DESERVED.
AS I SAID, WE ARE NOW IN A PLACE
WHERE WHEN WE USED TO PLAY 35%,
IT'S NOW 21.
THE WAY I CAN PAY FOR THIS IS
THE $40 BILLION, FOR EXAMPLE,
JUST MAKING SURE THE LARGEST
COMPANIES DON'T PAY ZERO.
INTRODUCE THE TASK CUT BETWEEN
25 AND 28, A COUPLE BILLION
DOLLARS, WE CAN PAY FOR
THINGS THINGS.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT DEFICIT
SPENDING.
I'M REALIZING AGAIN, GIVING YOU
TOO MUCH DETAIL.
>> Sean: I THINK JOE PROBABLY
GRADUATED FROM ONE OF THE MANY
FAILED PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOLS AND
STATES THAT ARE RUN BY HIS
FELLOW DEMOCRATS FOR DECADES,
BECAUSE HE'S PUSHING FOR HIGHER
INCOME TAXES FOR THOSE MAKING
$200,000 A YEAR, ALONG WITH A
HIGHER CAPITAL GAINS TAX, AND A
HIGHER CORPORATE TAX, THAT
CORPORATE TAX RATE THAT ALWAYS
GETS PASSED ON TO BECOME OF THE
PEOPLE.
ARE YOU WITH THE CONSUMER UNDER
BIDEN'S PLAN, EVERYBODY WILL PAY
THE PRICE.
WE WILL ALL PAY A TON MORE TO
FILL UP OUR TANKS, HEAT AND COOL
OUR HOMES, BUT DON'T WORRY,
DEMOCRATS KNOW HOW TO SPEND YOUR
MONEY BEST.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THERE ARE A FEW EXAMPLES OF THE
REQUESTS FROM DEMOCRATS IN THE
NEW SPENDING BILL THAT BRINGS US
NEAR $6 TRILLION IN SPENDING.
$1.75 MILLION FOR THE JAPAN
INSTITUTE IN PORTLAND.
VERY NECESSARY.
$2 MILLION FOR A PICKLE BALL
CENTER IN ORANGE, CALIFORNIA,
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR PICKLE
BALLPLAYERS.
$1 MILLION PLUS FOR A STATUE IN
SHEILA JACKSON LEE'S DISTRICT IN
TEXAS.
I THOUGHT WE ARE DONE WITH
STATUES, NOW WE ARE BUILDING
THEM AGAIN?
$7 MILLION FOR NEW PLANNED
PARENTHOOD LOCATIONS, $2 MILLION
FOR A PICNIC AREA IN CALIFORNIA.
WHAT ARE THOSE BENCHES, MADE
FROM GOLD?
WE CAN GO ON.
TONIGHT, THE BIGGEST CONCERN
INSIDE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
THOUGHT THAT JOE BIDEN WILL LIE
ABOUT THESE RADICAL SPENDING
PROPOSALS AND TAX HIKES, IT'S
THAT YOU WILL ACTUALLY TELL THE
TRUTH.
THAT'S WHY PRESS SECRETARY
CIRCLED BACK JEN PSAKI JUST
ADMITTED THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSTANTLY RECOMMENDS THAT BI
DID NOT TAKE QUESTIONS FROM
REPORTERS.
HERE'S HER ADMONITION.
>> HE TAKES QUESTIONS NEARLY
EVERY DAY HE'S ASKED AT THE
PRESS.
AT THAT SOMETHING WE RECOMMEND,E
COULD DO WHAT HE WANTS TO DO,
HE'S THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: WHY DON'T THEY
RECOMMEND TO?
PLEASE, JUST GET OUT OF THERE
QUICK BEFORE SOMETHING BAD
HAPPENS AS USUAL.
YOU'LL BE A GOOD PRESIDENT, IF
YOU'RE A GOOD PRESIDENT AND YOU
SHUT UP, WE WILL REWARD YOU WITH
COOKIES AND WARM MILK BEFORE
YOUR BEDTIME, SOMEWHERE AROUND
7:00 P.M. EASTERN, WE HEAR.
AT THIS ADMISSION IS NOT CLEAR
CONFIRMATION, THE ADMINISTRATION
IS STRATEGICALLY HEADING THE
PRESIDENT FROM THE PUBLIC AT THE
MEDIA, WHAT ELSE IS?
IF AMERICA HAD A NONPARTISAN AND
RESPONSIBLE, AND A FAIR AND
BALANCED PRESS, THIS WOULD BE A
BIG STORY, IF IT WAS ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, IT WOULD BE HUGE
STORY.
WE DON'T HAVE AN HONEST PRESS IN
AMERICA, INSTEAD, WE HAVE AN
ABUSIVELY BIASED CORRUPT MEDIA
MOB.
THEY PROTECT ALL THINGS
DEMOCRATIC, SOCIALIST, GREEN NEW
DEAL SOCIALIST.
IF THEY ATTACK EVERY REPUBLICAN,
ESPECIALLY IF YOU SAY GOOD WORD
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
OF COURSE, THIS IS A COMMON
THEME ON JOY REID'S SPARSELY
WATCHED A SHOW ON MSNBC, FOR
EXAMPLE LAST NIGHT ONE OF HER
GUESTS ACTUALLY SAVING THAT THE
G.O.P. IS A BIGGER THREAT THAN
AL QAEDA, USAMA BIN LADEN, AND
THE TALIBAN COMBINED.
THAT'S A RECORD, TAKE A LOOK.
>> I'VE BEEN THINKING TO MYSELF
THIS WHOLE TIME, AL QAEDA, USAMA
BIN LADEN, THE TALIBAN, THE
PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO DO HARM TO
OUR NATION AND OUR WAY OF LIFE
AND DEMOCRACY, THEY GOT NOTHING
ON WHAT THIS REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
DOING.
WE ARE A TWO-PARTY SYSTEM IN
THIS COUNTRY, THAT'S HOW IT WAS
BUILT FOR BETTER OR WORSE.
WHEN ONE OF THOSE TWO PARTIES
BECOME THIS RADICALIZED AND WITH
A CORE OF THE PARTIES IDEOLOGY
IS ANTIDEMOCRATIC, THAT'S A VERY
DANGEROUS DEVELOPMENT GOING ON
THAT'S GOING TO RESULT IN MORE
VIOLENCE, GOING TO RESULT IN
MORE ATTEMPTS TO OVERTHROW OUR
GOVERNMENT, AND PEOPLE LOSING
LIVES.
>> Sean: I KNOW YOU'RE TIRED,
I WISH YOU THE BEST IN YOUR
RETIREMENT, YOU'VE GOT TO BE SO
PROUD OF THIS NEWSPRINT,
NBC NEWS, THAT YOU SPENT AN
ENTIRE CAREER BUILDING UP ONLY
TO BE SHATTERED IN MERE MOMENTS.
YOU SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE ON
THE LEFT, YOU ARE ALLOWED TO LIE
AND MAKE CRAZY, RIDICULOUS,
TOTALLY INSANE AND UNTRUE
STATEMENTS AND YOU CAN GET A
FREE PASS.
YOU CAN EVEN -- LET'S SAY,
RACIST SAYINGS OR RACIAL THINGS,
SEXIST THINGS, XENOPHOBIC,
HOMOPHOBIC, YOU WILL EVEN GET A
PASS IF YOUR DEMOCRAT AND YOU
CAN GET AWAY WITH ALSO CALLING
AFRICAN-AMERICAN CONSERVATIVES
PRETTY MUCH ANY NAME YOU WANT.
WE SAW THAT RECENTLY WITH
SENATOR TIM SCOTT.
IF YOU ARE ON THE RIGHT, IF
YOU'RE CONSERVATIVE OR
REPUBLICAN, NO MISTAKES, DON'T
EVER MISSPEAK.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU TELL THE
TRUTH, YOU RISK GETTING CANCELED
ANYWAY.
SOMETIMES, JUST EXISTING HAS A
CONSERVATIVE IN THIS PC WORLD WE
LIVE IN IS ENOUGH TO GET ANYBODY
BANISHED.
THIS WEEK CONGRESSWOMAN
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR
SUSPENDED FROM TWITTER FOR
FOLLOWING TOO MANY CONSERVATIVE
ACCOUNTS DO QUICKLY.
HOW DARE THAT PERSON DO THIS?
HER ACCOUNT WAS LATER REINSTATED
AND TWITTER NOW CLAIMS THEY MADE
A MISTAKE.
YOU HAVE NO CREDIBILITY WITH
ANYBODY.
I'LL BE HONEST, I DON'T BELIEVE
YOU.
IT TWITTER ALSO SUSPENDING AN
ACCOUNT THAT APPEARED TO BE
LINKED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NEW
COMMUNICATIONS PLATFORM FROM THE
DESK OF DONALD J. TRUMP, AS IT
TURNS OUT THE TWITTER ACCOUNT WS
REPORTEDLY NOT CREATED BY ANYONE
ON THE PRESIDENT'S TEAM.
JUST TO BE SAFE, TWITTER STILL
BLOCKING THE ACCOUNT.
ALSO THIS WEEK, FACEBOOK
EXTENDED THEIR BAN OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT INDEFINITELY.
IT THE FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF
MARK MEADOWS WARNING THAT THE
PARTISAN ACTIONS OF FACEBOOK,
TWITTER, WILL ONE DAY